[Applause]
right now as you can see it's 6.31 cents
a gallon or i remember it being 250 or
even three dollars i used to put 38
dollars to fill my tank up now it's
about that's what you saw between 70 and
90
i think that's crazy
you know work basically i have to use my
card to go to work but yeah i do want to
use my vehicle a little bit less because
of the gas
yeah look at that full tank
72-91
you know there's people that have to
support families and go to work and they
have to depend on a car so
i don't see why
this is not this should be a priority
for people to have affordable gas
a hybrid yes
so
in the city this is great gas mileage
the hybrid
i think it's disgusting what's going on
but i don't see why
gas prices should go up because of
our involvement in the ukraine
i mean
yeah if they want to support them fine
but why do we have to have higher gas
prices if that's the case
it's about 24 miles per gallon so
not great but it's affordable
great corporate grade
i think it's the entire system is
regulated on how many barrels
everybody's releasing and they always
like to play a supply and demand game
the supplies there they just choose
whether or not they're going to release
it so they can you know fix our oil by
barrel prices and continually charging
us more at the gas stations because they
want to keep the profitability up to
keep your shareholders happy
[Applause]
you